s'il a commis dix neuf n'a fait de bien
à personne il semblerait qu'il y en ait
un qui soit directement victime du virus
sans même l'avoir attrapé s'agit du
docteur michel cymes il faut pas donner
plus d'importance à cet arrêt donne à
voir si vous voulez c'est fou qui depuis
ses premières déclarations polémiques
minimisant le virus
il ya maintenant presque un an semble
avoir du mal à regagner le coeur des
français
j'ai tenu un discours qui s'est avéré
faux mais c'est une extraordinaire leçon
pour moi en tant que médecin et pour moi
en tant qu'informateur c'est en mars
dernier que le médecin animateur télé
était invité sur tous les plateaux pour
donner son avis sur ce mystérieux
coronavirus venues de chine et à
l'époque il avait grandement minimiser
les dangers non en juin selon peu
inquiet bon c'est un virus de plus c'est
que l'on dit souvent ce une forme de
grippe différentes sorties ratées au
sujet du virus qui semble avoir eu un
impact négatif sur son image
les en plus concret avec les audiences
de sa dernière émission avec seulement
1,73 million de téléspectateurs soit 7,2
pour cent du public son émission prenez
soin de vous sur la sédentarité a connu
un véritable échec chien tu fais démolir
par des réseaux ça va très très vite
qui en 2018 il était l'animateur préféré
des français en juin dernier il avait
déjà perdu cinq places dans le
classement cédant sa place de leader à
jean pierre pernaut à leurs mauvaises
audiences déclarations polémiques
michel cymes at il perdu sa cote de
popularité
alors non non aux terrasses ainsi
partagé oui qui tourne au net alors il
se trouve qu'il ya une phrase qui dit
que plus l'on parlait plus en la chance
de dire de bêtises et bien michel cymes
au début de la crise sanitaire il a
beaucoup parlé dans leurs rêves et tout
le monde a dit oui le problème j'ai
l'impression que lui n'a pas assumé ce
qui le dit il n'a pas assumé après il a
dit non j'ai jamais dit ça mais non ce
sont des gens qui ont des formes un
petit pot mais il a vraiment dit ça donc
à mon avis est là aujourd'hui d'en payer
un peu les pots cassés les gens se sont
un peu détourné 2,8
excuse moi tu étais vraiment de mauvaise
foi ce son mea culpa il l'a fait si
l'avait pas fait on lui aurait reproché
de ne pas l'avoir fait justement pour
moi michel cymès a un rôle à jouer
certes qui se mouillent beaucoup il
parle beaucoup quand on parle
effectivement on peut dire des conneries
il a fait son mea culpa
manque de pot pour lui c'est qu'on a su
en période pandémique aujourd'hui que
toutes ces missions médicales les gens
n'ont pas envie de voir ça en prime
aujourd'hui le soir à 21h oui ça aurait
dans le premier c'est aujourd'hui de
réels effets des cartons d'audience en
c'est vrai en trente ans de tabous pour
les tourner son mea culpa on va
justement voir un extrait il était à bfm
avec un bonnet de malherbe
et justement il fait son mea culpa
contraint de ce que vous dites les
icônes rires je crois beaucoup de
médecins mais moi je suis un peu plus en
vitrine que les autres j'ai tenu un
discours qui s'est avéré faux mais c'est
une extraordinaire leçon pour moi en
tant que médecin et pour moi en tant
qu'informateur on vous sent encore
touché quand même oui je suis un être
humain un mois quand alors même si je
suis pas sur les réseaux quand mes potes
m'appelle sans arrêt dans la journée en
disant on est avec toi on est avec toi
on est avec toi j'aime et vous êtes avec
moi c'est gentil mais qu'est ce qui se
passait mais tu te fais pas chier sur
les réseaux c'est terrible bon alors un
moment où vous la fermer et puis ça
s'est calmé mais
oui j'ai été touché parce que j'ai pas
si demain vous voyez sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'on vous bâché qui a pas de
raison vraiment objective et que c'est
plutôt injuste ballon dit ce moment
est-ce qu'il vous arrive après j'ai pris
du recul par rapport à tout ça alors
apparemment il souffre beaucoup du
bashing on va dire des machines sur les
réseaux et c'est vrai qu'il hisse
également livré sur ses prises de
position politiques qu'on lui a beaucoup
reproché
on a un extrait j'ai fait une erreur ça
veut dire qu'en fait on peut rien donc
je fus on peut pas dire on peut pas
s'attaquer aux politiques c'est surtout
que je il vaut mieux éviter parce qu'ils
ont des réseaux de dingue parce que dès
que je me suis mis à attaquer c'est un
certain nombre de personnalités
politiques sur leurs discours sanitaires
je me suis fait démolir par des réseaux
ça va très très vite
mais je vous savez j'ai ensuite j'ai
même reçu je peux vous dire je vous
dirai pas de la part de qui j'ai reçu
des messages pas très gentil sur mon
propre portable de la part de certains
politiques dans un sens quand les
politiques vous reprocher de nous c'est
plutôt bon c'est qu'il avait dû mettre
le doigt sur quelque chose qui
dérangeait certains sont certainement
ceci étant il dit alors danger lui plein
de choses hein de michel cymes bien mal
m'en a pris la prochaine fois live
je vais me modérer je vais fermer ma
bouche mais il faudrait qu'ils la
ferment véritable c'est vrai même si les
docteurs à tel moment ce monsieur dans
un cabinet à quel moment il soigne les
gens comme ça et et même lui le dit
j'étais plus exposés que les autres
c'est sûr frérot si tu fais que de la
télé toute la sainte journée alors que
tu aies jamais dans le canton kamini
mais il n'a pas vu le doute en lui c'est
nice et mais vous voyez il continue à
balancer la peur des bonnes idées
politiques qui balancent en ce moment
sur les amis stars qui voudraient des
pales pour avoir des vaccins
mais entre temps luis là il a envie d'y
aller ça c'est une rumeur je vous le dis
je vous le dis ça commence à tourner on
compose de se vacciner sous le manteau
ça c'est ma maison
lui même s'est fait vacciner devant
toutes les caméras je parle pas du tout
de l'homme michel cynisme de l' objet
télévisuel qui est un naufrage
et le problème c'est que comme il a la
carte ont continué à lui confier les
missions que personne ne regarde alors
alors qu'il ya plein de gens de talents
qui n'ont pas l'émission donc c'est
hallucinant vosges et il n'est plus que
dans la justification de ses premiers
trois erreurs on va reconnaître moi moi
je moi je il ya un gros décalage entre
sa popularité dans les sondages
oui tant qu'animateur et et n'ont jamais
été bon maintenant parce que ses
différentes prises de parole sur la
commune n'ont pas été bénéfique pour son
image ce qu'on a mais lui c'était ces
petites blagues dans le magazine de la
santé
vincent rire cette façon de moderniser
un petit peu la santé et la médecine se
refaire avons été très bien d'ailleurs
mais il a quand même la confiance vient
de reims télévision avec une nouvelle
émission qui arrive dans quelques
semaines à l'appel antidote qui débarque
le dimanche à 17h40 cartes et là ça se
veut pas sérieux ça se veut familial
scientifique et divertissant quid de son
talk-show d'ailleurs émis dans le pays
ab je sois en est absolument aucune idée
l'information sis à la maison qui avait
pris la place en fait comme si en
deuxième partie de soirée a été annulée
à la va vite pour les autres c'est fini
oui vraiment vous parler des sondages
mais ce que ce que dit michel cymes
justement et beaucoup dé nature le savez
peut aussi vous c'est qu'à un moment
donné quand on est dans une forme de
bashing médiatique on sait que ça influe
aussi sur l'image est forcément dans les
sondages automatiquement les gens sont
influencés et je dis pas ça pour michel
cymes même façon très générale faut pas
oublier que les médias on sait aussi
très bien à un moment donné m la
direction sur quelque chose qu'on veut
voir dans les sondages un moment donné
il est quand même médecin à la fois
personnalités politiques iep où il ya
énormément de jalousie les politiques
publiques public animateurs
personnalités publiques
donc forcément il attise les jalousies
on sait très bien dans le milieu médical
y en a dans mieux la télé y en a voilà
il ya un sens terriblement de conduire
deux voies qui peuvent le terme grippe
est si losira grippe a fait son histoire
d'amour on est taxé joué les faussaires
d'achat de ranimation dit les pierres
énormité aujourd'hui au début de la
pandémie
aujourd'hui daniel ça fait un an et demi
on ne connaissait rien ça a pris de
l'ampleur à cause de nadine morano en
fait qui a twitté et qui a lancé un
hashtag grippette cymes et il nie lui
que c'est ça qui a été de l'ampli
fallait soit il on va avancer